oh my gosh what do you mean how you know
how seventeen listening to Madonna's
lies la Bonita 22 but also like what's
virginity I was 19 dude I met on gay
comm or something dot-com is that real
you do exchange like emails did you get
my attachment the file was too large 16
Katy Perry but I kissed the boy and I
liked it sex sex I think 19 I was 17
when I lost my virginity and it was to
my first boyfriend age 18 not a hotel
did like roses flowers had a soundtrack
plan I lost my virginity to a woman it's
a lady Hey ladies
19 after I got my braces off I was like
I'm doing it at age 16 to my
heterosexual best friend
we were playing geometry wars how about
if we try distracting each other to see
who can still get a higher score oh my
god
Brennan I would say ballpark 15 I'm
pretty conservative actually less than
two and more than I can count on one
hand more than I can remember if it's
oral then yeah I don't know the whole
shebang between 10 to 20 full-on sex for
sure under 10 i legit don't know I can't
I don't I lost count I've been safe it's
thinking with fun that's how you figure
out what you want in life is to try
different things everyone you can and
then you'll land on someone that you
like more than the other one and it
happened
it can happen yeah I hear yes I don't
think I'm very adventurous than friends
with people who are really adventurous
and tell me about some of the crazy
shape they do I'm like damn I'm boring I
am very sexually adventurous
say yes top of the mountain like hiking
backpack adventurous no oh hi maybe when
I get older I'll be a little bit more
adventurous I mean back in the day maybe
I'm too old for that during grad school
I just needed you know some release
hashtagged or in my early 20s I was
sexually adventurous
now I'm not actually get older you lose
that urge to do it every hour of the day
my boyfriend just turned 30 what are you
talking okay you know I get sleepy at
night I'm ready for bed I don't go crazy
places maybe on a beach this is where
I'm like not that adventurous I would
say like a car in a car car is the
craziest place you guys know I have
boring sex I guess any kind of thing I
would say the movie theater but I was
pretty bothered because I actually
wanted to see the movies but then it was
things start going you're like all right
on the top of a stadium that was the
hottest probably a pool table so what's
a couple times I need to be somewhere
comfortable and clean probably an alley
once or twice that's your bathroom ask a
person everyone likes different things
don't be afraid to go all-in believe in
yourself
it's kind of like a mental game of like
you can do this and then you can watch
the teeth no teeth no to well maybe it's
just a little game no to you just like
no I don't know about eye contact it's
intense kind of creepy yeah if you just
hold it there you lay my cat
[Music]
I don't really discriminate I like tall
small big medium the back of the knee
what I'm just giving you the good calves
guys like but I'm definitely a chess guy
I really like white teeth a tall guy sex
one come to that you like daddies I
don't like daddy his love a good set of
chest hair I think a nice smile is super
high good posture throughout the years I
like cycle like oh I'm really into arms
this week
oh that butt is fantastic nice shape as
I've gotten older cared less about ABS
I'm actually like more into bellies now
every single part of a man is attractive
to me all the time all my gay friends
know them bleed ups it at all I think
for the most part no you reach maybe
when you first meet and you're not sure
what it is it's like a sister man yeah
yeah it's like hard to be attracted to
the sex that your friends are and not at
like some point be like what do you look
like without your clothes on I check out
my gay friends all the time I check out
everybody on it
I check out women I don't have feelings
for my friends oh my god no I have one
gay friend everyone always thinks that
we were together it's like mm-hmm
it's nice to have gay friendships where
there's just like no sexual interest are
you not sexually attracted to me I also
feel like I've slept with a lot of my
friends well I like I'm I heard that
really because I trust them I usually
love or care about them if they're open
to it and we aren't trying to start
something more than it's like why not
sleep with your friends why not take a
crazy chance is that Hilary Duff yeah
[Music]